18 de febrero de 2000 me mataron pero
como así que me mataron entonces quien
está escribiendo estas líneas yo yo que
sigo viva
con ese recuerdo también hay muchas
preguntas que me hago a diario y es
porque a mí
no entiendo por qué me pasó todo eso no
entiendo
porque ya tantos hombres que me
violentaron
ridley velasco vivió en primera persona
la masacre de el salado una de las
peores matanzas paramilitar en la
historia de colombia acusadas de
pertenecer a la guerrilla más de 60
personas fueron asesinadas miles
tuvieron que salir desplazadas y más de
20 fueron abusadas sexualmente
gigle y tenía 14 años
preferible que te olvides más de 400
paramilitares llevaron el horror hasta
las últimas consecuencias tras cada
asesinato redoblaban tambores yo vi a
asesinar aquí en esta cancha a 10
personas la conté casi 20 años después
de la masacre en 2020 la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos
ordenó medidas cautelares de protección
para hitler
hoy vuelve al salado su pueblo después
de siete meses
su destino habitual de desplazamiento ha
sido carmen de bolívar entre la
cordillera de los andes y el mar caribe
y a 20 minutos del salado
ying ley intentó suicidarse dos veces
tras su violación pero con 17 años
encontró un propósito y desde entonces
ha liderado procesos de acompañamiento
en su casa de carmen de bolívar se
encuentra la sede de su asociación
mujeres sembrando vida esto que tenemos
acá es el monitor de las cámaras de
seguridad que tiene pero su labor de
denuncia de la violencia sexual no gusta
a los victimarios
sigues en el territorio te damos dos
días para que salgas zapa y web [__]
lesbiana somos el clan del golfo
presente las amenazas han llevado a ir
ley a cartagena de indias han más de dos
horas de su casa sólo sale para ir a
visitar a su hermana esta fue condenada
por presuntamente enviar amenazas a jit
ley para no perder la protección del
estado
la familia de anuncia un montaje
judicial
ridley le lleva el almuerzo a todos los
días y cada día habla con ella por una
rendija
como a mucha mucha tristeza de lo de las
peores cosas que me ha pasado en la vida
ha sido esto